more than a million syrians have made
their way to germany in the last 10
years
and while each has a story to tell of
how they ended up here
some are particular my name is tara
kalaus
i am 31 years old i was born in syria
and grew up in damascus
i have lived in germany for five years i
studied law and i'm a human rights
activist
the syria tariq left was a war zone
where hundreds of thousands had already
been killed
many millions more were homeless rival
armed groups
vied for control of cities and for many
people the only option was to flee
[Music]
first through turkey then on to greece
and up the balkan peninsula into central
europe
the germany they arrived in was at first
welcoming
but facilities were often basic
i was just very happy because for the
first time in years i felt safe
at the same time i was shocked about the
living conditions for refugees
i arrived in dortmund and was sent to a
shelter which is in the middle of the
forest with no public transportation
around
undaunted tarek concentrated on learning
the language as far as possible
and in time to help the many people like
him
as grateful as tariq is he believes
germany needs to do more to improve
integration refugees face systemic
discrimination in this society
they're affected by racism and by laws
on asylum in residence
those are experiences that refugees
share and i want to work on bringing
about changes in these areas
tarek's solution is political he's
applied to become a german citizen
and persuaded the green party to select
him as a candidate in this year's
general election
never mind that the greens haven't
traditionally prospered in the place
tariq wants to represent
just by getting into the political
contest he's traveled further than any
other
syrian refugee in germany and if his
citizenship
does come through in time he's
determined to fight for a seat here in
september
dominic kane al jazeera at the german
parliament